réveiller les consciences c'est le
leitmotiv du collectif des masques
blancs vêtus de combinaisons blanches et
de masques vénitiens
ces derniers se sont rassemblés ce
samedi dans la commune de villefranche
sur saône près de lyon confinement
couvre-feu ou encore port du masque
la coupe est pleine pour ces militants
qui juge les décisions prises par le
gouvernement français
incohérente pour eux ces mesures incarne
une dictature sanitaires ou notre sens
collectif c'est d'amener les gens à se
questionner à se renseigner à essayer de
voir éventuellement quel autre source
d'information ils peuvent trouver sur
cette crise parce qu'on est quand même
sur un discours qui est unique
toute pensée qui irait à l'encontre
donnerait des arguments inverses se
retrouvent censurés ou ne passent pas à
l'écran et c'est quand même le propre de
ce qu'on a pas une dictature en fait
quand on est dans une pensée unique
alors ça fait mal de reconnaître mais
avons donné au moins laisser la parole à
des personnes qui ont des discours né en
autriche ce mouvement s'est popularisé
en belgique en février dernier avant de
s'inviter dans l'hexagone les masques
blancs c'est avant tout une chorégraphie
martial saccadé et volontairement
provocatrice le tout sur une voix off
robotique qui énonce les différentes
mesures mises en place sous l'oeil
curieux des passants éviter tout contact
humain lesquelles un enfant dans la
quarantaine est la solution pour contrer
la pandémie se présentant parfois comme
les fantômes de la résistance
les masques blancs souhaite à travers
cette performance exprimer leur
ras-le-bol que nous on a atteint les
limites qu avec lui même
avant quoi je tente avec eux vous
demandez gilet jaune
là on a eu une loi sur les matches qu'on
n'avait pas le droit de tenter de
masquer maintenant on y dépose un match
il ya un truc qui date à quoi ils
travaillent à la loi sécurité globale il
y avait là on en a on nous en rajoutons
rajoutera ajouté clip les masques blancs
que c'est pour nos enfants quoi qui qui
arrivent pas l'esprit chico que masquer
toute une journée pour moi en tout cas
c'est inacceptable présent dans
plusieurs villes de france les masques
blancs veulent inscrire leur mouvement
dans la durée
marquer les esprits en pointant du doigt
des mesures qu'ils jugent liberticide
tout en prônant le retour à la fête et
au rassemblement